Objects with UVs and textures can be imported into 3JS. I won't be describing
this process, as it doesn't have all that much to do with the principles of
computer graphics. See the additional course materials for more information.
What's important to know is how the UVs of an object affect how the texture is
mapped to the surface. The basic principle is that by changing the UVs, we
select a different part of the texture. Here are the textures that are attached
to a single model. The way in which a model is associated with its texture is
called texture mapping. The spheres and other objects we saw before had fairly
natural projections of the texture onto their surfaces. For a more complex
object, such as this humanoid, an artist uses a modeling program to assign the
parts of the texture to the model. When a triangle mesh has a texture applied
to it the texture is used by the whole mesh. Because of this, a single texture
is used to hold all the different images for the various parts of the mesh.
This kind of texture is called a texture atlas or a mosaic.